a friend welcome back to the sage audio
channel today we'll be discussing
mastering for folk music we'll be
covering how you can process your folk
master and what settings make it sound
great also we'll be listening to some
examples so stick around for the full
video but first if this is a topic that
you find interesting I'd highly
recommend looking into the blog post
that's associated with this video you
can find a link for that in the
description box below also if you're an
artist engineer or producer and you have
a mix that you need mastered send it to
us at sage audio comm will master it for
you and send you a free mastered sample
of it all you got to do is set up this
short account upload the song and we can
do the rest folk music has always put an
emphasis on natural sounding
instrumentation that's layered and
complex yet it maintains its immediacy
and intelligibility sonically speaking
folk music can have a full frequency
spectrum with a lot of things going on
but still maintain Headroom dynamics and
space amongst the instrumentation
present now with that in mind let's
delve into some of the production
elements of mastering folk music that
make the process unique from mastering
other genres so how dynamics should a
folk master be all in short a folk
master should be more dynamic than pop
or hip-hop music but not as dynamic as
jazz or classical music in other words
folk music should be consistent
dynamically but not significantly
compressed or limited when mastering
folk music parallel compression should
be used as a means to preserve the
transience of the original signal and to
avoid noticeable compression
additionally soft knee compression and
optical compression can be used to
create a smoother sound one that's more
indicative of older recordings so again
for a smooth sounding master use optical
compression with a soft knee setting
additionally decrease the attack time
and increase the release time these
settings will capture the transients
sooner and compress it for longer in
turn making the music sound smooth and
tranquil for a more aggressive sound one
that retains the original transience of
the vocals and instrumentation use
modern compression with a hard knee
setting
additionally increase the attack time
and decrease the release time now these
settings will allow more transients to
pass through the compressor unaffected
and only compress the signal after
crossing a varied
find threshold in other words your
signal will be compressed less next
let's consider how you should eat cue a
folk master and when it comes to
mastering folk the right equalization
settings are just as important to
creating a natural folk sound as
compression and distortion
equalization should be applied very
carefully and in a minimalistic way to
significant of a boost or cut and ruin
the balance of a folk recording and when
mastering folk music using larger
bandwidths will result in a more
realistic and musical sound whereas
small bandwidth sound unnatural and
causing more noticeable change to the
mixes Tambor but that said here are some
cue settings that you can use to create
more natural sounding equalization
curves for a two octave bandwidth you
can use point six six seven as your cue
for a one octave bandwidth you can use
one point four one four as your cue and
for a half octave bandwidth you can use
two point eight seven one as your cue
now the most natural sounding of these
cues is the largest two octave setting
this might be too broad to equalize in
the way you want however if the changes
you make are small maybe 0.5 DB to 1 dB
then even these large settings will work
well for a folk master in addition to
using these settings it may be best to
use mid/side processing to have greater
control over the signal for example if
you'd like to make the vocal more
prevalent you could slightly amplify 2
kilohertz on the mid image and slightly
attenuate 2 kilohertz on the side image
this will make the frequencies that were
masking the vocal become less prevalent
these choices depend heavily on the mix
that you've received or that you're
working on so keep this in mind whenever
you're making changes to your frequency
response next let's discuss how much
distortion should be used on a folk
master 1 to 2 percent of total harmonic
distortion can be really beneficial to
the overall sound and presence of a folk
master harmonic generation causes a
signal to become more complex and full
as the gaps in the frequency response
are filled and the overall loudness and
presence of the track increases so if
you'd like to introduce harmonics into
your master you can use an analogue
emulation plugin and increase the drive
function now although these harmonics
can be introduced via these plugins acts
analog equipment does yield better
results the reason being analog
equipment creates subtle and complex
distortions and alterations to the
signal that are too nuanced to be
adequately represented in a digital
domain that said if you're looking to
create a folk master that sounds like
the folk masters of the genres heyday
then it might be best to utilize the
equipment that was around at that period
in time granted you can still achieve a
great folk master using entirely digital
processing it just really depends on how
you use the tools available the best way
to determine how much you should distort
your master is by listening critically
to the changes that the distortion makes
to your signal but you can also use a
total harmonic distortion meter on
saturation plugins or distortion plugins
to get a visual representation one more
thing to note if you are using
saturation plugins for your harmonic
distortion these saturation plugins will
also compress your signal that said it
might be best to avoid additional
compression if you intend to use a
saturation plug-in on your folk master
next let's consider how wide a folk
master should be the stereo imaging of a
folk master can be widened using
mid/side equalization this will
accentuate the imaging established
during the tracking and mixing sessions
now although stereo widening can make a
folk master sound better
excessive widening will quickly worsen
your Master's impact and presence I'm
inside equalization as opposed to delay
and phase based stereo imaging it's a
safe choice for widening your folk
master stereo image without introducing
unwanted phase cancellation and when
performing mid/side equalization you
have two options for widening the stereo
image the first is to increase the
amplitude of the side image frequencies
and decrease the amplitude of your mid
image frequencies or both by using
various filters the second is to alter
the output of your equalizer or adjust
your output span from mid to side a
quick way to make a folk master both
brighter and wider is to amplify the
side image with a shelf filter above 7
kilohertz this will amplify the higher
harmonics of the guitars and accentuate
any airiness in the master lastly let's
consider how loud a folk master should
be the loudness of a folk master can
vary based on the intended medium of
release
but if you intend to release your folk
master on a streaming service an
integrated negative 14 l u FS is a great
start if you'd like to create a more
commercial master negative 10 L u FS is
also acceptable now like most of the
information that we've provided here
everything needs to be taken with a
grain of salt how loud you should make
your folk master truly depends on the
mix the artists intentions and the
composition for example if the folk
master that you're creating is only
comprised of an acoustic guitar and
vocals then making that master negative
10 L u FS will most likely be too loud
the reason being that most other masters
reach that level of loudness by having
more instrumentation including but not
limited to drums and bass these
high-energy instruments are responsible
for a great deal of perceived loudness
that being said making a vocal and
guitar master as loud as a fully
fleshed-out arrangement it's probably
not the best decision if you're looking
for a way to set a loudness for your
fault
EP or album and the best way to do so is
by mastering your loudest most complex
track first the track you choose should
have the most instrumentation and have
the greatest amount of high energy
instruments like drum and bass now once
you've mastered this track to say- 10 L
u FS then master the other softer tracks
with this track as the reference a good
way to get these tracks to match the
reference is by matching the perceived
loudness of the vocal not the entire
track this way you'll end up with a
mastered album that sounds balanced
without any jarring or out of place
transitions from one master to the next
so let's listen to a before-and-after
fulk master with all of these principles
and forms of processing that we've
discussed for this master will be using
parallel compression equalization some
saturation some additional low-level
compression and mild limiting
you tell me you're nervous
you say you're afraid
I wish you could see bad
[Music]
I think your brain
Oh
if I pray
[Music]
I'll still be
I'll fix these mistakes
[Music]
wherever you're going
so these are our thoughts for mastering
for folk music but what do you think
leave your thoughts in the comments
section below also again definitely
check out the blog post where you can
find a lot more information on this
topic and others like it there's a link
for that in the description box below
also if you're an artist or an engineer
send us one your mixes at Sage audio
comm will master it for you and send you
a free master example all you got to do
is set up this short account upload the
song and we can do the rest thank you so
much for watching we really hope you
enjoyed it if you did please like and
share this video with your friends this
way we know if you'd like to see more
videos like this one also you can
subscribe to the channel we release new
videos every week and subscribing is the
best way to stay up-to-date there's a
comments section where you can leave
your thoughts on this video or a
suggestion for a future video and again
if you're an artist or an engineer and
you have a mix that you need mastered
send it to us at saige audio comm will
master it for you and send you a free
mastered sample thank you so much for
watching we'll see you in the next video